vous me poser beaucoup de questions sur
les réseaux sociaux et pis curieux et
sur youtube avec le hashtag by jamie et
notamment sur le corps humain et vous
n'y est pas allé de main morte c'est
parti
une question de candy neige andré d'où
viennent les boutons d'acné notre peau
produit naturellement une substance
grasse qu'on appelle le sébum son rôle
constituer un film sur la peau pour la
protéger des agressions extérieures sauf
qu'à certaines périodes de la vie il
arrive que l'on n'en produisent un peu
trop à l'adolescence par exemple à cause
d'une surproduction d'hormones sexuelles
dans ce cas les canaux par lesquels
arrivent le sedum peuvent se boucher le
problème c'est que certaines bactéries
sont friandes de sébum et se multiplient
dans ces zones d'embouteillages le corps
essaie alors de se défendre contre cette
invasion c'est à ce moment que les
boutons apparaissent ils sont d'abord
gonflé et rouge parce que la porte de
son augmentent dans la zone pour lutter
contre l'infection puis parfois ils
deviennent blancs à cause du pus qui
apparaît lorsque les défenses
immunitaires attaque les bactéries c'est
le prix à payer en quelque sorte pour
faire peau neuve pourquoi rigolo quand
on aux chatouilles c'est une question de
salomé on ne rigole pas aux chatouilles
comme à une bonne blague le rire des
chatouilles est en fait une réaction
émotionnelle une sorte de mécanisme de
défense face aux fans de liquide d'abord
lé chat tout une fonctionne que sur
certaines parties du corps les aisselles
ou le coup notamment de zones
particulièrement vulnérables car ici
passe de gros vaisseaux sanguins qui
réagissent plus intensément à la moindre
forme d'agression le contexte est
également important essayer de
chatouiller un inconnu dans la rue vous
verrez qu'il n'aura pas envie de rire et
puis il faut que les chats tout soit un
jeu partagé pour qu'on puisse en rire un
peu comme deux chatons qui se battent
pour de faux enfin il faut aussi un
effet de surprise c'est le fait
d'ignorer ou les doigts de l'autre vont
se poser qui provoque cette réaction la
preuve c'est qu'on ne peut pas se
chatouiller soi même regardez
s'enquérir que vous comment
fabrique-t-on novo et c'est une question
de sens bras pour faire simple
construire un autre c'est un peu comment
construire une maison il faut d'abord
une armature pour l'os elle est
fabriquée par des cellules spécialisées
à partir de protéines puis il faut des
murs qui rendront l'ensemble solides ce
sont le calcium et d'autres minéraux qui
a porté par le sang vont venir se fixer
sur l'armature tant que la croissance
continue c'est à dire jusqu'à l'âge de
18 ans grosso modo les cellules
construisent de l'armature et les eaux
grandissent mais il ne faut pas croire
que nos héros se fige une fois la
croissance terminé les eaux sont vivants
et sont sans cesse renouvelé on estime
qu'au cours d'une vie le squelette est
entièrement renouvelé
quatre fois dernière chose sandra plus
on bouge plus on rend nos os au lit donc
plutôt que de regarder le sport la
télévision mieux vaut le pratiquer en
chair et en os 6 jonathan fléau emma
savoir d'où vient l'expression perdre la
boule
de l'argot jonathan à partir du 19ème
siècle le mot bull devient un terme
familier pour désigner la tête logique
l'homme a plutôt une tête rom pour le
coup on ne peut pas dire que nos aïeux
se soit trop creuser la tête de la même
façon on parle aussi de coups de boule
pour désigner un coup porté avec le
crâne et puis le monde ou l'évoquent
également le globe terrestre eric quand
on perd la boule on a de bonnes raisons
d'être déboussolés et de perdre un peu
le nord aux états unis on a préféré les
billes aux boules avec l'expression
toulouse sûrs marbles perdre ses billes
qui veut dire perdre la tête
les boules
pourquoi est-ce qu'on tire la langue
quand on est concentré c'est une
question dabla bla 25-18 des chercheuses
britannique en psychologie se sont aussi
posé la question et pour y répondre
elles ont observé de près des enfants
chez qui le phénomène est fréquent quand
ils sont en train de réaliser certaines
tâches et l'a surpris contrairement à ce
qu'on imagine ce ne sont pas les tâches
qui demandent le plus de précision qui
entraîne le plus de sorties de langues
ce sont celles qui impliquent une forme
de communication quant à l'enfant par
exemple s'amuse à faire les gestes
inverse de son camarade cette
observation validerait d'ailleurs la
théorie selon laquelle le langage a
évolué à partir des gestes en résumé
lorsqu'il s'agit de communiquer les
mains et la langue sont liés et quand on
se concentre pour bouger les premières
la seconde sont automatiquement c'est
peut-être pour cette raison que je bouge
les mains quand je parle et j'ai du mal
à tenir ma langue
question de hugo pourquoi pleures ton
quand on m'a mal l'être humain et bien
d'autres animaux sécrète des larmes pour
protéger leurs yeux mais nous sommes les
seuls par contre à pleurer lorsqu'on
social ou en cas d' émotion très forte
des scientifiques ont essayé de
comprendre mais ils n'ont pas réussi à
décrypter tous les mécanismes qui
entrent en jeu dans cette histoire une
visite thèse est que les pleurs servent
à attirer l'attention agréé par exemple
pleure pour signaler une douleur ou une
envie il s'agit donc d'un mode de
communication pour les annuler c'est
peut-être la même chose une façon de
communiquer de se soulager de quelque
chose que l'on a du mal à verbaliser
sacha de marseille veut savoir pourquoi
le rin et jaune
c'est à cause d'une substance contenue
dans le sang la bilirubine il s'agit en
fait d'un déchet qui provient de la
destruction des globules rouges une fois
qu'ils sont usés et qu'ils ne servent
plus quand le sang passe dans le foie
pour y être débarrassé de ses impuretés
la bilirubine est retenu et se retrouve
dans la bile elle est ensuite évacué via
les urines comme elle contient un
pigment jaune elle colore les urines en
jaune plus vous buvez d'eau plus la
couleur est diluée en revanche si vous
êtes déshydraté les urines sont un jaune
très soutenue pour l'anecdote est les
participants au vernissage d'une
exposition difficulé en 1958 eu la
mauvaise surprise de voir leur urine
devenir bleu fans de cette couleur le
peintre avait en effet ajouter un peu de
bleu de méthylène au cocktail servi
pendant la soirée autant vous dire
qu'ils s'étaient tous un peu vert
retrouvé s'est jamais du lundi au
vendredi à 16h55 sur france 5 où dès
maintenant sur france 3 tv le lien est
sous cette vidéo et surtout n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner et activer la cloche
faites le savoir
[Applaudissements]